Paris was the scene of the latest effort
to find a diplomatic solution EU foreign
ministers met with US Secretary of State
John Kerry and Russian Foreign Minister
Sergey Lavrov Western powers have urged
Russia to enter into talks with
Ukraine's new government it's hoped that
face-to-face talks will defuse the
crisis today we are trying to use every
diplomatic opportunity to bring Russia
and Ukraine into direct contact with
each other at a senior level but such a
meeting is proving difficult to engineer
there has been some movement on the
diplomatic level but Russia still
refuses to recognize Ukraine's newly
installed government it also denies
sending troops to Crimea and claims
local defense groups are behind the
seizure of strategic bases on the
peninsula speaker euros you have a fatal
punished I'd like you to explain to me
what you mean by pro-russian forces if
you're referring to the self-defense
forces created by the Crimean people we
do not have any power over them because
if people would show but the West
accuses Russian forces of taking over
and threatening Ukraine's territorial
integrity and NATO says Russian actions
are threatening peace and security in
Europe earlier the Ukrainian defense
ministry said Russian forces had
partially ceased to ukrainian missile
defense bases in Crimea Cape Fear
lantana Sevastopol and yes pittore a
further north german foreign minister
frank-walter steinmeier has called for a
contact group to be set up to deal with
developments in Ukraine the outcome of
talks in Paris is likely to determine
the agenda for Thursday's meeting of EU
leaders and Brussels delegates there
will consider whether to impose
sanctions on Russia